[Music]
welcome back to cvs saturday morning the
city of los angeles swore in a new fire
chief yesterday and for the first time
in history
of the department she is a woman kristin
crowley will lead the nation's third
largest firefighting force in our second
biggest city as a push for diversity
continues in a male-dominated field
joint benedict takes a look at both the
history of women firefighters and how
crowley hopes to encourage more to sign
up
they are the first on the scene
from the air on trucks
and on the ground they are our rescuers
and our defenders
but hidden among the storied precision
of helmets and overcoats
our nation's firefighters are taking on
a more feminine flair coming from ohio
that's where i was originally raised
i've never seen a female firefighter but
now crystal renault
is one firefighter actually approached
me in the gym and said you know you work
really hard i see how strong you are and
city is actually
open for applications i think you should
apply she and haley denney are part of
the newest class of probationary
firefighters in the city of los angeles
the only two women to graduate in their
class you've probably only done what
like 12 shifts
[Laughter]
[Music]
and although they are new they've known
from the beginning they are different
what are the challenges of being a woman
size
i would say that was probably my biggest
hurdle i think learning just technique
of every different movement is was a
really
big thing to try to overcome this
equipment isn't built for someone that's
you know five foot four and a hundred
and
maybe thirty pounds soaking wet some
days and as they toured the city's
firefighting museum they realized how
rare they are of the city's 3700 sworn
firefighters only about 100 are women
nationwide female firefighters still
only make up around 8 percent of career
hires making the pressure to succeed
even stronger i want to be able to
perform to the point where someone knows
for going to the fire crystal has my
back the first known female firefighter
dates back to 1818 an enslaved woman in
new york city named molly williams in
los angeles there was the society of
matrons a volunteer brigade of lady
defenders back in 1910 but despite being
founded in 1886 l.a didn't pay a woman
to put out fires until 1984.
now 38 years later
it is my pleasure to be the first to
congratulate
los angeles has its very first fire
chief who happens to be female the 19th
fire chief of los angeles city fire
department it's pretty incredible and i
don't take that lightly chief kristen
crawley joined the department 23 years
ago after finishing an internship as a
paramedic as soon as i went to the fire
station i thought this is what i'm
supposed to do once on the job things
weren't always easy many times i was the
only woman in our whole battalion do you
think that the way women are treated in
fire service has changed in the last two
decades i think it has changed is there
room for growth absolutely in the lafd
there have been allegations of sexism
and harassment something crowley says
must change it's a really perfect
position to start
and to prioritize that work environment
especially from the diversity equity and
inclusion side and even chief crawley
admits things were far from perfect in
her career the eyes are on you but
they're on you just a little bit longer
just say can you do the job it's like
yes i can do the job and i'll show you
she says she was frequently being tested
and even had to deal with other
firefighters taking her position in the
field forcing her to prove herself again
and again somebody would run to the base
and just to make sure that i could throw
the ladder it was a test so i'd throw
the ladder and then i'd have a little
talk and say you know what that's my
spot so don't do it again crowley says
the key to fixing that is having more
diversity on the department
which is why they offer girls camps and
outreach it's going to make us a
stronger team so we can ultimately
serve the community in a better capacity
because in an emergency every
firefighter may have different strengths
but they all do the same job at the
academy there's no breaks for being a
woman right
it's all the same
and even though renault and denny have
the same grit and determination as their
male counterparts they say seeing a
change at the top
is exciting there's so many women out
there that might not even know that's
possibilities it's not just
about being a woman it's about anyone
being capable
putting out flames busting through
barriers and igniting a passion for all
brave enough to answer the call
for cbs saturday morning joy benedict
los angeles
love that she's been doing it for 23
years i know she says as soon as she
walked in
to that first firehouse she knew yeah
what she wanted to do she got that
feeling this is huge for diversity she's
not only the first woman also the first
lgbtq person to to take this position
and how great is it that the first fire
fire that was a woman was in 1818 molly
williams a
woman who volunteered so many firsts
yeah he's got it all our community yeah
yes gotta love it